hey guys i'm ryan wright and i'm jerry
today we're gonna check out the second
trailer for marvel's daredevil on
netflix exciting stuff
first trailer looked pretty cool i'm
excited to see what this one's about but
before we get into that you can skip
this next part and hop straight to the
trailer we're going to give some shout
outs or a shout out i'm going to give a
shout out i do want to say i'm not one
of those youtubers who
likes to divulge his personal life
struggles especially his current day
struggles but
i did want to say thank you guys because
you are the one consistent thing in my
life next to this man right here who
keeps a positive loving thing going on
in my life except for you haters [ __ ]
you haters you're all a bunch of stupid
ass losers do nothing but hate on people
on the internet [ __ ] losers and but
man i just want to start up this love
fest but also [ __ ] you i did want to say
thank you guys so i'm doing shout outs
right now i wanted to give a shout out
to a woman named amanda jones amanda
jones now she posted on the shout out
page that she wants me to do a video for
the trailer unfriended i'll have you
know amanda i did but you post on the
shout out page so you deserve a shout
out she has a picture of minions on her
facebook says you don't have to be crazy
to hang with me i will train you whoa
you don't have to train she'll train you
how to be crazy so then you can hang
with her oh she's crazy i thought she
was implying that she's a sex trainer
like a bunch of guys ride her no she
rides a bunch of guys and they go on the
sex train with amanda that's not what
she's saying at all well i once knew a
girl named amanda
no total [ __ ] that's horrible it's a
little [ __ ] to this day i haven't spoken
her for about two years but i'm going to
assume she's still a flat out [ __ ]
really terrible i'm a little bitter
today people
no but amanda jones you look sweet you
look honest any lady subscriber i am
very grateful for because you are one
out of 16 people so thank you and if you
do become a sex trained all the more to
you what do you mean what's this what do
you mean sex training like everyone
rides the amanda train sorry amanda
unless amanda's really into like super
kinky stuff i get maybe maybe the irony
is that she'll really forget the vibe
and she's one hell of a horny girl
you never know you never know her last
name's jones you know what they say
about amanda jones right
amanda jones last name bones
what's the thing what they say about
that that's a brilliant last name is
jones or just yeah just this one manager
i once seen this guy named keith jones
did he bone
nah he was disabled
oh daredevil's disabled so it kind of
fits he's a handicap that's a disability
is that
[Music]
it was in my
blood and i'll finally do anything to
make it a better place
[Music]
it's vincent de inforno
yeah
sometimes the difference between the two
is a sharp line
sometimes it's a blur
sometimes we have to do things outside
the law
we're going to make a difference i know
it doesn't feel like it sometimes but we
are
they're blind but you see so much
i hear things you know what they call
stuff like that give them
i'm gonna train
[Music]
there's only dirt quarters
i'll keep you safe karen
i have to be the man
what are you gonna do
whatever it takes
does not make you good
i respect your conviction the lone man
thinks he can make a difference
[Music]
maybe she had an iron suit or a magic
hammer
that would explain why you keep getting
your asses added to you
[Music]
that's pretty ba well justice is blind
this season justice is always something
convenient that also pertains justice
can't see what it's doing but it's doing
something it feels like it's a darker
version of what we've got an arrow and
flash kind of if you took like the tone
of the punisher movies and mix that in a
little bit yeah yeah i mean it's cool
punisher would be a great netflix show
have you seen adi shankar yeah
yeah i mean this guy who's playing
daredevil looks like he's doing a much
better job than what ben affleck had to
offer us and
years ago
scott glenn as stick i mean he's a cool
he's kind of a creepy mentor to have you
know like it's scott glenn who's always
a little creepy in his own way like i
wouldn't want to be a friend with scott
glenn well i'd rather be friends than
like on his [ __ ] list oh yeah i know
because i feel like he creepy i feel
like he would punish you with like his
penis in some way
that's no that would be terrible no
punishments should should involve
penises unless they're punishments and
it's like okay but we have a safe word
that's what daredevil was originally
learning how to do a bondage story is
this originally a story yeah they would
like he would have sex with people and
then they would tie stuff around his
eyes and then he would be like there's
no point in you doing this because i
already can't see i mean i'm hoping we
get like some really cool characters in
this show you know like it's cool that
they have kingpin as like the main
villain wilson fisk uh i learned that
and they got him played by a great actor
the acting um doesn't look like
powerhouse performances you know it
looks a little ch on the cheesy side it
does fit for what it is what i like
about it is i know marvel is clearly
involved in this one unlike
a lot of marvel films and even agents of
shield which makes sense
it doesn't look like it's trying to
become a part of the avengers you know
yeah i think it looks like its own
separate thing it seems like it
acknowledges that universe at least
wants to be its own thing and i think
it's really cool that they're doing
these tv shows and stuff like that
really translating comic books into
cinema because if you take the movies
those are kind of like having like a big
trade paperback that's like one long
story yeah and then a tv show can be
several issues and an arc i think if we
had the budget for tv i think most comic
book movies would serve better as tv
shows yeah and this seems like a hero
like i don't know everything about
daredevil but this seems like a hero
that would work where you don't need a
massive yeah because he has his powers
but they're not like so intense that you
can't like pulling the flash off on tv
that's more ambitious than trying to
pull off a daredevil show daredevil is
something that is more realistic more
grounded you don't need mega tons of cg
i mean it's cool they got charlie cox in
it because he's you know he's continuing
the legacy of hiring british actors to
play american icons
those british people and australian
people can act they can act they're
great actors vincent um don't forget
that how you say it dinofreyo yeah
i've been calling him dion forno
i thought you were joking
no that was a very serious response
that's a hard name to pronounce it is
and there's the apostrophe in there so
is it like dionofrio or is it just
ginofrio i've always heard it is vincent
de nofree encounter is like part of that
league of richard jenkins actually
league of extraordinary richard j
because everyone's richard jenkins
league of extraordinary underrated
actors jk simmons has got a lot more
acknowledgement lately but you know like
vincent um
he's a chameleon in a lot of ways any
role he does you feel like he's been
typecast as that role even though
they're all different yeah
he's so good at like any role he does he
can be
so lovable and so trusting and in one
moment can be creepy as [ __ ] like in the
cell or in men in black or or men and
black it's great in that he had a level
of humor and he's in law order criminal
intent that's where criminals have
intention
oh good i'm glad they got one show for
that daredevil is a very gritty world i
hope they really commit because they're
on the netflix platform yeah you know
that's like
having an hbo platform or a showtime
platform like you can go all out and i
hope they don't pg-13 this [ __ ] i'm
wondering because you know it's it is
marvel still you know it's like they
really want this daredevil world
involves sex drugs alcohol and violence
it's everything the girl from true what
was your [ __ ] name dave ryan wolfe
yeah she's [ __ ] hot
she's really hot you see your tits a lot
on trueblood and i hope you see your
tits in this show i did some research
that's right
preparation h raymond
i
what she at one point gets addicted to
heroin and does
pornography
which is a whole other show that we
could watch that would be a great
spin-off series now we're gonna sound
stupid here but is a lecturer in this
show i don't know i feel like we should
do research before we start recording
if that's the new tone if we gotta get
deep man i know the bigger the channel
gets the more people expect us to be
smart this is just a wild guess but i
bet that elektra is the kind of
character where it's like if she's gonna
be in the show they'll release they'll
like introduce her late to be like oh
[ __ ] look who's here well they tried
spinning off her character in the movie
which did not go over so much which is
why i feel like to bring her out right
away i feel like they to get people on
track with daredevil yeah and then bring
her in so then they can like rebuild
elektra's public that's what i like
about this first season at least what
they're promoting from it is they got a
simple premise daredevil
bad guys who are ruled by wilson fisk
that simple
yeah they should keep it like that for a
while you're gonna say wilson phillips i
was like country band no charlie wilson
from charlie wilson's tom hanks movie
it's like a simple plot and like one
thing that i get worried about
especially if they have a tv universe is
that they would do villain overload like
up front yeah it doesn't look like
they're doing that they're keeping it
grounded at first
well it seems like they're gonna do some
some sort of origin because it's
appropriate we don't have a daredevil
movie five minutes ago it's been a long
time it's gonna be all the details my
friends all on the
details the dates the deets the dates
the deeds arrive at a mandatory you know
anyway guys
thanks for mentioning that trailer was
out trailer was out if you're new to the
channel you know you can do you can
subscribe to my dick [ __ ]
i'll try to marry i don't know just you
can subscribe to the real rejects jerry
has a playlist on this channel called
reasons to jerry you're hairy jerry
i cut that other part out of the title
that was the biggest mistake even i'm
sorry everyone wants to jerry or harry
jerry and you can follow us on instagram
twitter and facebook
where we are so [ __ ] fun to
look at our posts just
joyous yeah so thin you get to see me
promote pictures from stills from the
channel that you could watch in moving
form
and you get to watch jerry take
interesting art photos time for us to
tune out but until next time hey
thanks for coming stopping by that's
what people say when they go on the
imaging